a lot has happened so here is a horror
movie news Roundup first thing A
Nightmare on Elm Street recall in
development from blumhouse I don't know
how reputable his account is Brad Miska
from Bloody Disgusting says that this is
not true however our man Jimmy champagne
has apparently heard from reliable
sources that you know maybe it is a
little bit true Maggie Gyllenhaal is
remaking Bride of Frankenstein and
apparently Christian Bale might be in it
a lot of the time when you get these
remakes of older movies in the modern
day there's some kind of twist on it
that says something about our modern
society like if you look at the
Invisible Man that came out in 2020 Next
News Christopher Landon is directing
scream seven I think that's great news
this guy gets it when it comes to teen
horror he did the two happy death Day
movies he did freaky the saw X trailer
is now out and this one's going to take
place between saw and saw two it's going
to be more in line with the original
Seven Saw movies and talk to me the raka
raka developed Australian horror film
apparently made 10 million dollars on
its opening weekend it survived the
barberheimer onslaught and finally we've
got news on FNAF it looks like it's
going to be rated PG-13 it's running at
around three hours long which is very
surprising I'll be going more in depth
on these Topics in their own videos so
drop me a follow if you want to see more